fünf tipps so retten sie ihre payback
punkte vor diebstahl
tipp 1 ändern sie regelmäßig das
passwort ihres e mail postfaches denn
dort geht dieser dieses hecking los
tatsächlich wenn ihr e-mail-postfach 1 x
gekapert ist dann greifen natürlich die
ganoven auch sehr sehr schnell auf ihr
payback konto zu tipp 2 -speicher nsi in
ihrem konto nie zu viele punkte nicht so
viel anhäufen dann haben ganoven noch
mehr beute
tipp 3 lassen sie ihre payback punkte in
bargeld umtauschen das macht payback
nicht so ganz einfach das heißt diese
funktion ist leider versteckt also
suchen sie einfach in hilfe auf der
webseite nach bargeld dann finden sie
auch diese funktion
tipp 4 zeigen sie niemanden ihre payback
nummer es sei vielleicht der kassiererin
im laden aber sonst bitte niemanden und
it 5 s bringt in der regel nichts wenn
sie sich bei payback beschweren weil
perfekt weist die schuld von sich
tatsächlich werden sie probleme haben
melden sie sich bei bild und wir
versuchen ihnen zu helfen